first up my flavor pack lamb with fry
bread whether I'm cooking high-end
dishes or rustic dishes trust me
it all has to be impressive so this lamb
dish proves that you have to spend a
fortune to create delicious food first
off the panel this is a lamb steak and
it's cut just above the leg just here
because you see that delicious bone
running through the center and that's
full of marrow so that just gives the
lamb a nice added sweet flavor just take
your knife cut through each end this
stops the lamb steak from buckling so
therefore it cooks evenly and colors
beautifully salt and pepper lamb needs
quite a little help to the pepper so if
I generously the pepper I just Pat that
down the pans just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so I'm depending on the color
of the lamb steaks are really sort of
impart a lot of flavor the noise you
want to hear you can't hear that noise
don't drop the steak in put a little bit
of garlic in there not chopped garlic
this hole close the garlic lightly
crushed don't even waste time peeling
them in tongs lift up a bit of fat
around the bag that's on the top of the
leg tilt the pan and let all that fat
render rendering is a chef's term that
means melting the fat it works
brilliantly when you're cooking a ribeye
as well coming over
[Music]
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we got that nice even sear all over as
it's cooking just tilt the pan and base
and base in the LEM steak just means
this sort of adding all that nice
scented garlic olive oil back into the
lamb useful have a lamb out let the lamb
rest
now for the perfect rustic crouton
so this bread is quite firm color
days-old just slice it straight down the
center dice it up put into a bowl season
it beautifully from there and add some
milk
sounds strange adding milk to a crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture and just let that mill
sort of absorb into the bread while
that's soaking unlike the dressing go
back to that initial garlic that was in
the pan
beautiful and for pesto mortar and
chievous anchovies go brilliantly well
with lamb on there nice salty vinegary
flavor and a big kick some capers there
little baby cats very sweet now just
pound that to a nice paste the smell is
incredible next some Dijon mustard a
nice teaspoon and a half in open up red
wine vinegar 2 tablespoons and then our
extra virgin olive oil now it's got that
heat in there got a nice roasted garlic
a real hearty chunky vinaigrette that
sort of seeps into that lamb some fresh
parsley crunch up the parsley
delicious flavor past the end nice now
get your pan hot for the croutons olive
oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk am not too hard
I don't them dry and in viola and the
milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor that's the color what nice now
take them out and lightly drain them rub
it kitchen roll onto the board out I
[Music]
plate them just take it's amazing
vinaigrette and spread it bill there's
croutons listen to them my little
boulders hitting the plate the lamb sit
down on next one on rest the croutons on
now use all those little bits and my
chef in Paris would kill me right now if
you saw me using those because they're
the ugly scraps that customers should
never see but but they're the best bits
croutons on and then just drop that
sauce and whiz little bits on the lamb
and there is a perfect way of taking a
cheap cut who's the Premier League of
dishes
literally as a stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically
through the richness of the coconut
gives it that nice little bit of acidity
goes fantastically well with a cinema